uh because money they like money
everything they do is
this is where my tech nerdside comes in
everything they do
is to keep people on that platform
longer and to keep them looking at more
ads and watching more videos and earning
them more ad revenue
they have no reason to get rid of 70
something million people like this
like they're not going to infinity wars
us because they like our money
you know they like our eyeballs they
want to do it so i don't think it's
going to happen
how do you make some sense of all this
stuff like i'm always looking around
when i find voices that seem kind of
sane and interesting and like somewhat
trustworthy how do you find people
because people always
people literally come up to me at the
supermarket they'll be like dave you're
the only one i trust
and i'm always like well [ __ ] we got a
big problem here
people say that to me too they're like
you're the only one that tells the truth
and i really pride myself on that i'll
keep telling the truth and throwing in
my silliness and
the fun part is that i love being wrong
because then i get to learn
the right thing so i don't even care if
i'm wrong but i trust
i'd say i trust you i trust ben shapiro
minus 10 because i'll just make up for
the silly
because it's in there um i trust
rogan's show joe rogan's show yeah um
and it's not even that i trust their
opinions i just trust that they like to
learn
so his guests and him they'll work their
way through [ __ ] i like that
i trust erica who is the ceo of barstool
sports
and pretty much the whole barstool
sports crew i think they tell it like it
is too
yeah kind of kind of crazy that bar
stool has to be so involved in politics
though right
it's really funny it's really really
funny and
this is why i'm saying the pendulum's
coming back when this
the people who are supposed to be
serious have gone
crazy then the crazies are gonna have to
take over
and we're running the asylum and we have
more experience this is the thing
they don't they don't get it they're out
when we go crazy we're gonna be way
better than them
but are you afraid that if trump
does not pull off this stuff with the
lawsuits and stuff and and biden becomes
president
that at that point why wouldn't big tech
just get rid of all of us you know
they're calling us all nazis anyway the
entire political establishment will say
you're a bunch of nazi trump supporters
i don't like to say it publicly
obviously okay okay
i was i was under the impression nicole
the son this on youtube
oh okay all right yeah i'm so sorry like
i thought you were like
a gay nazi yeah my bad
but but really like are you afraid of
that that like why wouldn't you know
you've built
your life and career and all that
goodness on the to on the pipes of
youtube and facebook and twitter and
instagram and all that
like are you worried that you know
january 20 rolls around biden's
president and within the next couple of
weeks like why would big tech not just
boot everybody who's deplorable and a
bad guy and a nazi and the rest of it
uh because money they like money
everything they do is
this is where my tech nerdside comes in
everything they do
is to keep people on that platform
longer and to keep them looking at more
ads and watching more videos and earning
them more ad revenue
they have no reason to get rid of 70
something million people like this
like they're not going to infinity wars
us because they like our money
you know they like our eyeballs they
want to do it so i don't think it's
going to happen
it's not in their best interests and
this is what i
hope tv hop tv network of tv networks
learn too many thoughts at once
red bull um sweet jesus slow down woman
they're
i'm trying i'm trying they're just
playing to one side
and there's 70 other million people to
entertain you dumb asses
guess what all those people do they buy
toilet paper they buy makeup
they buy hair products you clearly do
wow um
it's it's wow it's amazing i mean the
hair game if we toured together would be
seriously like strong let's just have
our hair on
t-shirts like just the outlines of our
hair i like it that'd be fun nicole and
dave
nicole and dave that's my brother's name
too so it's fun um
yeah i just think it would be really
stupid of them economically
to not start playing to the other half
of america and north america people
forget that canadians very much follow
american politics and chime in on it
because we're attached we're your hat
and uh yeah what's going on i think i
don't think
what's going on with your guy up there
trudeau you must love that guy huh
that robot malfunctioned a while ago we
gotta like
hearing hearing him in between doing
blackface
telling us how to be good people is just
it's too much for me
he talks in a fake robot voice now
it's it's just too much how did he how
did he win a re-election like because
most western
countries and now it's a little up in
the air with the us but in the last like
five years most western countries
they they went to the right but you guys
you went the other way and now he's
talking great reset
the humanoid that he is great reset yeah
okay
bring it um which is probably why i get
at least 100 people asking me every day
to run for prime minister
and they're not kidding and i've had
financial backers
ask me if i would do it they want me to
run for governor of california now
you see what you do how stupid is this
i mean arnold kind of broke the mold for
us like years ago so that's pretty good
but i don't want to be prime minister
the salary cap is 180 000 canadian
that's frankly like
nah you know for all that pressure
that's like
23 american not into it um
but yeah that takes me down another
tangent yeah but
what do you think i would get people
like that trudeau like like what
what is happening in canada
he's gonna be out soon the thing is we
just didn't care enough
canadians follow american politics
more than we follow canadian politics it
just is what it is
yours is more entertaining it's more fun
the characters are better it's a good
reality show
ours is kind of like where and we're too
polite there's not a lot of fighting
in our house of commons and we just kind
of let things skirt by
until suddenly this douchebag is talking
about the great reset and his robot
voice
um then it's getting a little weird and
he's fighting with
the premiere of ontario about giving
the cash advances to small businesses
that they promised over a month ago
then i'm like okay who's who are we
tagging in here because now someone has
to go take this guy out like
election-wise not like take him out yeah
i got it you're not calling for the
assassination of justin
i am not calling for the assassination
of justin trudeau facebook did you hear
that
okay because you know i've gotten in
trouble jokes before with facebook
listen the media matters people
they watch this show with a keen eye
waiting for me to pause the wrong way or
for one of my guests
to accidentally say something because
skype freaked out for a moment so we
have to be very careful you do not
want justice is that true yeah these
people are pathetic
ridiculous fools
tell me what you really think at least
they didn't send you to your fiery death
to rescue horses
that were fine you see there you go
wait do you guys think it's a little
weird you guys you canadians we don't
really understand you people up north
do you guys think it's weird the way
that that we that it seems like our
issues have been imported into canadian
shores because
every gig that i did in canada and when
i was with jordan when i've done solo
gigs
people are crazed and starving for the
types of things that i talk about and i
did an event with
um maxine bernier who was the people's
party of canada you know
basically the libertarian candidate for
prime minister and we did an event and
anti-fo was there and they were throwing
things
and attacking us and screaming nazi that
video you probably saw that video of the
woman with the walker
trying to cross the street that was for
me to come to canada to talk about free
speech like
insane but but and then you have all
these people and they're screaming black
lives matter and all this stuff and it's
like
well are is there a problem with police
shootings in canada and does it have
anything to do with race and then you
ask them and they're like no
no that's like well what are you
screaming about
no just we want to play yeah we want to
play tv that's what it is
that's what it is literally i just when
canadians start going off about issues i
laugh most of the time because i would
say our number one
issue if we have issues outside of
pandemic and stuff like that
is environmental it's where we gonna lay
pipeline uh for natural oil
what you know indigenous lands can we go
through what's not cool
let's let's make peace with the
indigenous indigenous people
those are the real issues canadians have
and i'd say number one is environmental
other than that we're kind of chill and
i think that makes some people antsy so
they make up problems just like everyone
else in the world
they have nothing to complain about so
they make it up i just remembered
something i don't think i told you
did i ever did i ever tell you that i
messaged you while you were in hamilton
ontario
oh during that for that that was for
that gig right
yeah i didn't know you yet but i saw
that that was happening
and i reached out to i think on
instagram and i offered you
a another venue with a ton of security
yeah
nicole you are a good woman i i need
help in hamilton
this is gonna sound very douchey i don't
run my instagram
that's okay it does but it's okay
no i mean i got a guy that runs it and
sometimes messages sometimes things slip
through well i appreciate i mean that
thing really was i was like i cannot
believe
this is happening in canada i got people
screaming that i'm a nazi
the three speakers on stage you had a
christian a jew and a muslim on stage
and they're screaming that it's a white
supremacist event
you guys failed at white supremacy so
hard yeah
so hard so hard hitler would be hitler
would be very
very disappointed so i was about to ask
you what's next for you but i think we
know what's next which is you've got
some sort of late night situation coming
that's awesome
i do and it's going to be fun and i know
i sound a little like
evil villain about it but that's how i
feel i feel like okay
you guys want to play you pushed good
people this far
the people's champions are rising up or
we're gonna swing and
i can't just be like oh it's just me i'm
gonna take on everybody there's a
freaking
x-men crew rising up right now and man
i feel bad for snl i feel bad for these
people that are stuck in the little
boxes
can't say what they want can't be real
comics because yeah
the good ones are common if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell